komme ich machen jetzt neuanfang marie
guck mal hier kannst du das hey leute
und herzlich willkommen damit zum neuen
video
wie finde ich das so belegt ein
feuerzeug alter und der tisch ist total
dreckig mal gut dass meine eltern das
noch nicht gesehen hier ja ist ja an
sich neu der tisch und hier ist ein
fleckchen fleck ist kirsten vielleicht
jeden fleck ist hier ist ein fleck etwas
gedacht und damit herzlich willkommen zu
19 bio häufig ich habe das natürlich
geht es gut wir kommen auch direkt zum
thema und zwar jetzt am titel
wahrscheinlich schon gelesen es geht
heute um ipads es geht weiter mein
restposten projekt geht in die nächste
runde
ich weiß nicht viele von euch haben
sicherlich den ersten paar mit den
laptops gesehen im zweiten part hatten
wir dann smartphones das war allerdings
ein ziemlicher flop muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen jack die videos auf jeden
fall super gerne ab falls die noch nicht
gesehen haben wir haben gerade ich habe
mir so ein konto erstellt wo halt dieses
ganze geld rhein fließt was ich mit den
sachen verdiene und wir schauen einfach
mal wie viel ich verdienen kann wenn ich
euch hier super gerne mal ein
wir lagen bei 1700 euro ich habe am
anfang 1380 euro selber eingesetzt also
mitgebracht und habe dann halt schon gut
400 euro verdient mit verkäufen und der
kontostand betrug dann irgendwie 1715
euro glaube ich ich hab euch gefragt was
soll ich mit dem geld machen wie soll
ich's vermehren wo kann ich investieren
um das gewinnbringend zu verkaufen wie
auch immer viele von euch fanden
konsolen waren super interessant leider
ist sie zurzeit ausverkauft vor
weihnachten werte keine paletten mehr
und dann habe ich ein anderes angebot
gefunden was ich sehr sehr geil fanden
einfach weil ich in diesem angebot das
größte potenzial gesehen habe und zwar
verkauft der typ ipads wir müssen mal
kurz reinschauen restposten ipads viele
verschiedene modelle mit verschiedenen
gigabyte größe
du willst 1 haben also es geht heute auf
jeden fall auch wieder einen gewinn raus
allerdings nicht an dich du kannst mir
als abkaufen ich mache gute preis 140
euro hier auch schon das angebot apple
ipad 2 oder 4 16 32 64 gb usw
übrigens leute ist das hier die
leistungsbeschreibung da steht einfach
sogar nur apple ipad 4s wird gehandelt
für 229 euro unser preis ist bloß 960
euro
abwarten wenn die in einem halbwegs
guten zustand sind kannst du die auf
jeden fall für 130 140 euro verkaufen
und deswegen hab ich da großes potenzial
drin gesehen einfach mal für 800 euro
mit versand bestellt die sind jetzt
angekommen wir schon mal rein ich hoffe
es sind keine sachen dabei
das hier ist auch schon das paket es ist
wirklich echt schwer heute wieder das
ringen der lieferant ich habe jetzt
schon zum zweiten mal bestellt der hat
mir noch überraschungen rein getan hat
ja gesagt deswegen bin ich gespannt was
ihr drin sein werden und wie wir das zu
geld machen können weil gerade habe ich
logischerweise nur noch irgendwas unter
1000 euro auf dem konto
falls ihr allerdings ideen habt wo ich
rein investieren soll
was ich mit dem geld machen soll
schreibt es bitte in die kommentare das
ist so wichtig ich bin also darauf
angewiesen und ich freue mich immer über
eure ganzen ideen
okay das sieht doch schon mal nicht
schlecht aus hier ist wirklich viel drin
es wert super wichtig dass die ipads
scheiße ich habe gehofft hier sind auch
in der originalverpackung das sieht
leider schlecht aus aber egal
eines davon wird auch wieder verlost wir
sind ja hier im adventskalender nach so
einem moment mal kurz ist marie kannst
du mir einmal bitte helfen und mir das
ipad mini geben
ach so okay doch mal kurz wir verlosen
kainz hiervon es wird dieses ipad mini
verlust im wert von über 450 euro glaube
ich 64 gigabyte einfachen kommentar
schreiben ihr könnt alles schreiben und
ganz ganz wichtig ist dass sie irgendwie
euer instagram eigene e mail von euch
dazu schreibt damit ich euch
kontaktieren kann weil man kann über
youtube leute nicht mehr richtig
kontaktieren so wie das früher ging das
wusste ich nicht deswegen ist das super
wichtig damit der gewinner das dann auch
save erhält also und teilnehmen könnt
ihr nur weil wir den kanal abonniert und
ich werde das ab jetzt immer auf meinem
instagram auflösen da heißt sich alex
wie könnt ihr mir gerne folgen oder so
wenn der boxer einfach da personen und
jetzt geht es weiter an starten am rhein
ein ipad 2 ipad 3 pets reiter hier sind
hier sind voll viele handy hüllen drin
von deinem
wie heißt das noch mal nein dieses diese
handy idol auf 7143 45 ja kommen dazu
sagt ja dann macht es eben also der hat
wirklich ziemlich viel reingepackt aber
dass wir alles nur wenn diese eigentlich
hat er mir kopfhörer versprochen 78 19
10 ipads und jetzt haben wir hier noch
ganz viele protective cases ahv-alter
was machst du das also was ich hier auf
jeden fall vorfinde sind alte ipad kabel
also bei einem also wir haben wir auf
jeden fall eine menge handy hüllen die
werde ich es nicht einzeln verkaufen
also wenn irgendwer handy hüllen braucht
mach ich mache wirklich gute preis da
kann ich auch nicht viel zu erwarten das
ist ja völlig klar im die werden alle
auch auf meiner instagram seite gepostet
die seite verlinkt ich euch in der video
beschreibung da könnt ihr gerne rein
schauen da gibt es immer cool angebote
von mir und jetzt machen wir mal die
ipads ich bin echt gespannt ich hoffe
wir haben hier gute produkte bei jawoll
alternativ das schon sehr gut 800 euro
haben wir auf jeden fall schon mal ein
ipad 2 16gb die wollen auch wieder ein
ipad haben meine eltern haben ja letztes
mal auch schon einen laptop gekauft
das müsste zwar interessiert das ist
aber auch ein ipad 2 kommt es ja mal an
mache vielleicht ist da ja noch hier
gilt alle auf jeden fall also ich muss
sagen die dinger das hier zum beispiel
hat eigentlich keine überhaupt keine
kratzer dass sie hat hier unten einen
kleinen kratzer eigentlich auch ein paar
trier ich habe ihn extra vor gefragt
die sind sauer
die sind von 2002 ohne witz rate mal
kann es mal kurz obmann auszupacken
ich habe auch die smartphones bei den
bestellt und die waren alle kacke weil
die fotos vom angebot seien viel besser
aus ich habe ihn extra gefragt bei den
ipads weil es wäre natürlich geil wenn
auch ipads vier dabei sind weil die noch
ein bisschen teurer sind und er hat
gesagt er hat gesagt es sind fast
ausschließlich nur ipad 4 mit 32 gbyte
ich habe noch kein einziges ipad viel
gesehen alter wenn das jetzt schon
wieder das uns gäbe dass hier hat auf 16
gigabyte kann wieder mich verarschen
ohne witz ich hab den extra gefragt ich
meinte so klopp schon
das ist alles ipad2 apple ipad 2 32 gb
10 ja das ist ja ein witz oder ehrlich
das macht das regt mich so auf wie kann
man denn sagen wenn einem kunden per
e-mail fragt sind da wirklich auch ipads
hierbei in welchen größen ungefähr
darauf schreiben ja fast ausschließlich
somit 200 megabyte und da sie nur ipads
2 decker das macht mich wirklich
aggressiv mein ipad 2 kannst du auch
noch gut 420 euro verkauft und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr reue
mit 32 oder 64 gigabyte keine frage aber
trotzdem nervt mich dass gerade und so
handy hüllen kriegst du heute auch
überall im theater geschlossen vor allem
für einen samsung galaxy s 7 naja
immerhin sind die ganzen ladekabel auch
dabei ich weiß nicht ich muss mal
schauen für wie viel ich die anbieten
kann ich versuche natürlich so gering
wie möglich zu machen aber trotzdem was
ich irgendwie ein bisschen was daran
verdiene weil es ist natürlich auch
aufwand für mich also ich werde dir auf
jeden fall alle mal checken und dann
über die seite verkaufen da könnt ihr
super gerne eine nachricht schreiben
wenn ihr an einem interessiert so helfen
wir natürlich auch sehr viel meinen
restposten projekt einzeln jedoch
angemacht oder welches waren dann aber
was ich gut finde die haben nirgendwo
kratzer die displays sind alle gut in
schuss also jetzt legen wir was drauf
also sieht auf jeden fall ganz normal
aus dem einst hoch fährt man kann
youtube und alles kannst alles sogar
machen so ist es nicht trotzdem regt
mich das auf was ist das denn für dieser
lieferant also ich kann dir auf jeden
fall nicht für mehr als 110 euro oder
120 euro verkaufen und ich hab halt auf
die ipads 4 gebaut weil ich die 140 oder
150 euro safe verkauft hätte können aber
egal es ist halt echt dafür sind die 800
euro das ist nicht wahr ein guter preis
das ist der hat mich eigentlich voll
abgezogen also na ja der krieg der
saftige melden ich denke ja nicht zurück
ich mache jetzt das beste mit leute ich
endlich aus dem schnitt ich habe eine
sehr gute nachricht und zwar mit dem
lieferanten kommuniziert und wir haben
uns darauf geeinigt dass wir noch ein
geiles ein mit 4 mit 32 gigabyte umsonst
schicken wird also das kann ich auch
noch verkaufen und 71 kurs geht raus
also mit den laptops war ich sehr
zufrieden die smartphones war scheiße
die ipads sind sohn eigentlich auch
nicht gut aber ich freue mich sehr auf
eure kommentare in was ich noch ein
investieren soll was soll ich kaufen und
wir sehen uns dann übermorgen wieder
vielen dank fürs zu schauen wir mal
gespannt was ihr so dazu sagt haut rein
job das regt mich ja nicht auf